acting is a profession that requires a
lot of Versatility and a willingness to
test boundaries often this bravery pays
off with a critically acclaimed
performance that's lorded for years or
even becomes cinematic history sometimes
however it results in a complete
nightmare for everyone involved based on
the 1980s TV show of the same name The
Equalizer Stars Denzel Washington as
Robert mcco a widower who works at a
hardware store when he's not busy
killing bad guys in the film's climax
mccole lures some murderous Russian
gangsters to his place of employment
where an explosion sets off the store
sprinkler
[Music]
system looks boss right well Washington
told Cinema Blend he quickly got real
tired of being so damn wet but by that
third day right at about 11: at night
after a 13 now day I I
disagree it still looks pretty
bustar actress Maro Robbie had a pretty
bad time making Suicide Squad first of
all her character Harley Quinn wore
skimpy outfits that made her feel
self-conscious and she kept accidentally
poking herself with her spiky gold
Bangles Harley Quinn nice to meet you
but when the Washington Post asked
Robbie what scene was her least favorite
she had an answer at the ready she
absolutely hated filming that scene
where Quinn throws herself into a vat of
white ooze Robbie says she was utterly
repulsed because the nasty stuff kept
getting into her ears and nose I
couldn't breathe and I tried to open my
eyes and it would glaze over my eyeballs
and I could only see why it was horrible
actor Chris Hemsworth isn't too thrilled
about undressing on screen these days
hey sorry I tased you he was perfectly
fine being shirtless in the first Thor
film but increasingly got annoyed at
those gratuitous scenes starring his abs
when Thor the Dark World rolled around
Jos Weeden insisted he stripped down
after a big battle sequence speaking
with MTV News Hemsworth admitted he was
hesitant so and he said Chris get your
shirt off and I said well I don't know
you know what's the why what are we
doing the issue came up again during
Thor Ragnarok and the shirt came off
again Hemsworth told Access Hollywood he
was relieved he could keep his shirt on
during the Thor film but director Tao YT
felt the film needed some eye candy and
then taer Midway through shooting came
up and said I think we need to put some
bums on seats I I think we need to get
the shirt off and I was like no I don't
want to see that they did
though
[Music]
it's fun playing the biggest bad guy in
the universe just ask Josh Brolin he
crushed it as Thanos in Avengers
Infinity war and he reportedly really
enjoyed tearing the Hulk a new
[Music]
one but broland says he wasn't
altogether pleased about having to kill
Loki
[Music]
according to Brolin actor Tom Heston was
obsessed with getting Loki's last scene
just right so filming became quite The
Bitter Sweet bummer broland told USA
Today Tom was so vulnerable at that
moment so choking him out wasn't the
most fun thing I ever
done I don't feel so
good directed by Quinton Tarantino the
hateful eight was a Lighting Rod for hot
takes and angry opinions but music
lovers probably had the best reason to
hate the film especially since Kurt
Russell destroyed a guitar that turned
out to be a Priceless
antique music time's
over w w w Russell thought the guitar
was a prop but it was actually an
instrument from the 1860s and worth over
$40,000 the incident really Shook Up Lee
as she'd fallen in love with the antique
and Russell was devastated by what he'd
done hell I'm already regretting this
speaking to billboard Lee explained that
Russell felt terrible when he discovered
his mistake when he found out his eyes
literally welled up it ended up being
great for the scene but very sad for the
guitar and for my guitar teacher and for
me it's rare that a romantic comedy
comes along and breathes new life into
the genre but when set it up hit Netflix
critics were delighted by The Tale of
Two employees trying to get their bosses
to hook up starring Zoe Deutsch and
Glenn pal the film takes a predictable
turn when the two matchmakers fall in
love themselves in the film's most
celebrated scene the two co-workers
share a late night pizza which Sparks
the
romance this is the best meal I've ever
[Music]
had unfortunately for Deutsch filming
the scene wasn't exactly romantic that's
because she devoured four entire pies
while shooting that scene and threw up
halfway through the shoot and then she
had to get very close to Glen pal in
order to finish the shoot she told hello
giggles I think he looks at me in a very
different light critics weren't the only
ones who found 50 Shades of Gray
alarmingly unsexy based on the runaway
bestseller book of the same name the
2015 film stars Jamie Doran as the
snoozester Johnson as his willing slave
I need you to show
me what you want to do to me punish me
show me how bad it can be unfortunately
filming all those bondage domination and
torture scenes could be pretty bad
Johnson spent hours tied up blindfolded
and pretending to be struck by a whip
she told Time Magazine it's really hot
not in a steamy sexual way it's just
sweaty and it's not very comfortable she
said the sex scenes were so taxing she
started thinking okay let's just get
this over with coincidentally that's
exactly what we were thinking halfway
through 50 Shades of Gray maybe the most
memorable scene in Titanic is the one
where Kate Winslet's Rose character asks
Leonardo DiCaprio's Jack to draw me like
one of your French girls it's a
passionate moment showing her character
overcoming the disapproval of her fiance
and mother to claim her own agency and
embrace the man she's fallen in love
with a paying
customer I expect to get what I want but
now obsessive fans try to get Winslet to
sign pictures of herself naked and she'd
love for that to stop she told Yahoo
news quote I don't sign that picture it
feels very uncomfortable why would you
do that end quote why indeed Taylor lner
played the werewolf character Jacob in
the Twilight series and his
Transformations usually left him
shirtless if not completely naked fans
loved it but lner worries now that his
pecs might overshadow his acting he told
a show biz quote if I had to choose I
would never take my shirt off again in a
movie but I guess that's not very
realistic I certainly won't be asking to
do it though end quote in the 2013
action comedy kickass 2 Jim Carrey plays
a superhero called Colonel Stars and
Stripes who's gruesomely murdered by
super villain a few months after the
film was released Carrie publicly
condemned the level of violence in the
film After experiencing a change of
heart in the aftermath of the tragic
Sandy Hook massacre which happened
shortly after he'd wrapped up filming
his scenes quote I did kickass too a
month before Sandy Hook and now in all
good conscience I cannot support that
level of violence I am not ashamed of it
but but recent events have caused a
change in my heart end quote while
that's a respectable stand to take the
bosses at Universal Pictures probably
wish Carri had figured that out before
taking the role passengers is a science
fiction Adventure starring Jennifer
Lawrence and Chris Pratt despite the
star power of its cast it didn't do very
well at the box office partly due to
backlash against a crucial plot point
that involves a startling disregard for
the consent and personal autonomy of one
of the characters which wasn't helped by
Jennifer Lawrence admitting that she
spent the sex scenes too drunk to
remember doing them she told CNN she had
Jitters about the shoot because it was
going to be her first time filming a sex
scene and also felt guilty about doing
so with Pratt who's married quote I got
really drunk but that led to more
anxiety because I was like what have I
done I don't know and it was going to be
my first time kissing a married man and
the guilt is the worst feeling in your
stomach end quote in Basic Instinct
Sharon Stone plays writer SL murderer
Katherine trell who uses her wit and sex
appeal to easily manipulate the men
around her especially in the iconic
scene where by simply uncrossing her
legs and flashing the cash during a
police interrogation she completely
reverses the balance of power it's
[Music]
nice which is sort of ironic because
according to Stone the scene itself
turns out to be born of manipulation and
a violation of consent Stone claims she
was asked by director Paul ver hovind to
remove her underwear because the flashes
of white were messing up the shot she
was assured there would be no nudity
visible on camera and didn't discover
she had been tricked until she saw the
finished film in a room full of other
people she responded by slapping
verhoven who has publicly denied Stone's
claims saying it's a lie in The Phantom
Menace Terren stamp plays Chancellor
voram who's ushered out in favor of the
secret Sith Lord Palpatine thanks to a
vote of no confidence from Queen amadala
played by Natalie Portman it's about as
exciting to watch as an actual Senate
hearing but it's important to the
overall plot or what passes for one
stamp signed on to the movie for the
sole purpose of getting to act with
Natalie Portman however when he actually
arrived on set Portman was nowhere in
sight and stamp was directed to aim his
dialogue towards a piece of paper on the
wall instead he told indiewire it was
just pretty boring which not
coincidentally also sums up the entire
[Music]
movie